有個人說,不用等了,我們已經在裡面。
他叫Kevin Kelly,美國的科技雜誌Wired,1993年創刊,他是第一任執行主編。
2016年,他在必然這本書裡寫,以前通了電的東西,接下來都會通上AI。
這是Podcast Photorology今年9月上線的訪談。
到他家裡錄的提問的Nils Gilman,來自智庫Berggruen Institute。
他不只發問,自己的看法也講了不少。
起點原本是物理學的詞。
科幻作家Vernal Vinge把他接來談AI的未來
等AI聰明到能做出更聰明的下一代
智力會一路爆炸下去
Kevin Kelly從Vinge的定義講起
那是什麼
那是語言
再說一遍
人們沒有語言的那些人
根本無法想象
在語言過後
世界會是什麼樣的
那是無法達到的
那是他們無法接觸的
因為語言而發生的所有事情
就像是一種單純性
開放了整個新的土地
並沒有任何人能看到的
以前的語言
對
而這個單獨性的問題是
你在這個單獨性中
並沒有顯現
沒有一刻
有些人坐在一旁說
等等
你明白我們現在在做什麼嗎
對
我們在聊天
是的
我們有語言
在距離上的悲傷行動
哇
這太棒了
這將會改變一切
所以這並沒有發生
單獨性的東西
基本上只能在背景中看到
對
So we are in a singularity in that sense
接下來他講矽谷想錯的地方
他會用到一個機器學習的詞
過度擬合
意思是模型把練習題背得太熟
換一種題目就不會了
but there's a myth about it
而這個秘密只是關於智慧
So there's something I call thinkism
- 嗯哼,對。- 認識主義是這種…
- 在一個大膽的意義中。
- 對的。
- 認識主義的解決方式就是
- 更多的思考、更多的智力。
- 對。
- 這些人說的,
- 通常是一些年輕人,
- 喜歡思考的人,
- 認為思考是世界上最重要的東西。
- 對。
- 因此,
- 這種廣泛的智力定義,
- 我並不認為
- 這其實是最重要的東西,
就是智能
所以在智能上
有一個重點
就是智能
現在我認為
需要更多的研究
就是智能的合作
但我認為
在智能模式上
現在我們有
智能模式
非常優秀
在製作
那是很好的在製造智慧
那是在製造智慧
所以我們有一個
很好的在製造自己
很好的智慧
現在最好的是
它可以用來
更好的智慧
所以這太過分了
因為這是一個
這是我們想要的世界的強弱感
因為這種智能、智能是非常強弱的感覺
是一種思考的感覺
尼奧斯接著問
這幾年大家覺得世界變得很怪
連什麼是真的都沒有共識
這種不穩定是不是就是穿過起點的感覺
我並沒有使用堅定的構圖
我使用了不確定的構圖
我覺得我們正在進行的不確定性
我們進入的一部分
而帕爾瓦是這個想法
的失去真理
我們的文明的基礎是
我們是人類的本書
對
文章 聖經 法律 法律
所有東西都被寫下來
那是一個永恆的 monument
黑色和白色的
非常非常決定和固定
而且那裡的作者
So we had truth and authority
And now we moved on to the screen
螢幕的人們
並非書的人們
It flows, it's ephemeral
And you don't get truth from authority
你必須在這一刻處理好
Niels說很多人受不了這種不確定
所以反AI的聲浪越來越大
焦點是資料中心抗議它吃電耗水
它才資料中心成了看得見的出氣筒
大家真正怕的是那個說不準的未來
它是它們的大小
如果它們是小小的東西
如果它們是大小的東西
它們就不會擔心了
但它們的大小和資本主義
我認為
它們的大小和資本主義
尼奧斯同意
他還覺得AI公司自己在火上加油
這些公司快要上市
高層跟員工會一夜致富
其中幾家卻公開說
10年結束前白領工作會少掉一半
根據我們的看法和關係
我認為我們沒有預期足夠
人們可以做的新東西
和會做的新機會
我們只在考慮更換
因為是比較容易思考的
尼奧斯說
經濟學家把這叫勞動總量謬誤
以為工作就那麼多
被機器拿走就沒了
他擔心的是過渡期
一個55歲的會計
未必來得及重學
他還預測
下一屆美國總統大選會圍著AI打
圍著AI打
而我認為,我們…
我認為我們有四大驚喜
並非車輛駕駛員和電腦技術員所威脅的
Right.
Who was predicting that?न
Nobody.
Yeah
所以這個想法,我們都能看到車輛會輸了,我不認為我們能看到
訪談後段,談的是信仰,凱文·凱里自己有基督信仰
尼歐斯問他,戲谷講起點的口氣,很像教會在講末日跟救贖,這是巧合嗎?
我覺得有點關於這種想法,
我總是把這種想法當成是地球上的相似
或會把我們全都殺死
就像是沒有其他之間的
這對我來說很愚蠢
我認為這就是其他之間的
所以我認為
至少有一個相似的
意味著
異性是
一種奮鬥
然後你遭遇了
死亡的宇宙
但我不相信宇宙
我認為它們是很危險的
可以想像
要想象的,
Kevin Kelly的答案是
起點已經到了
只是身在裡面的人看不出來
接下來的日子落在天堂跟末日中間
一次只好一點點
還會帶來一批新問題
原影片100分鐘
他還講了Anthropic
找各宗教的人去幫忙教Cloud分辨好壞
他自己也被找去
另外
他認為基因編輯擋不住
人類會分成改造過
跟沒改造過的兩群
原影片連結在說明欄
有興趣可以去聽更多